c'était il ya dix ans en 2006 que se
crée la première agence immobilière à
vocation sociale à la règne baptisé
soleil pour solidarité et investissement
locatif
cette agence s'est fixée comme mission
d'aider les personnes en situation
précaire à accéder à un logement c'est à
dire que comme une agence classique
nous gérons des biens brocante de
propriétaire la différence c'est que
tous ces logements sont destinés à des
personnes démunies
donc pour ce faire nous avons une sont
fédérés au niveau national à la famine
la fédération des associations pour
l'insertion par le logement qui donne un
agrément et nous sommes bien entendu
aider par tous nos partenaires que sont
l'état le département les
intercommunalités et la caisse
d'allocations familiales
lagence soleil est né d'une idée est
portée par des valeurs celle d'aider les
personnes expulsées porteuses d'un
handicap victimes de violences
conjugales à accéder à un logement
décent
cette arrivée s est une réponse voulue
par le département de la réunion dans le
cadre du volet logement de son plan
départemental de cohésion sociale
je m'appelle de michel de volontat j'ai
63 ans et je vais à saint denis depuis
quelques années j'ai été logés par la
junte ce soleil là se sont petit studio
où c'est très bien mais j'ai pas
toujours été aussi bien j'ai vécu
beaucoup de galères aussi
arrivé il ya dix ans à la réunion cet
ancien viticulteur passionné de rugby se
retrouve après une séparation sans
logement il doit faire face seules aux
difficultés de la vie et sans aucune
aide
michel se résout à occuper un cabanon
dans l'ouest de l'île vers l'est puis
avait rien d'autre part je peut valoir
la télé parce qu'il n'y avait pas
l'heure j'écoute un peu le posteur pas
ce qui a pris le blâme est née après la
journée d'hier était de revenir été
beaucoup d'un art en soi on ne tape à la
porte je me dis voilà sous tendu vous
avez quelques semaines pour quitter les
lieux pour partir et comme j'avais aucun
contrat y avait rien là j'ai jusqu'au
théâtre le fait aujourd'hui d'avoir un
logement par l'agent soleil quelques
qu'est ce que ça a changé ma vie au
vietnam a permis de relever la tête
quand même parce que vous quand vous
avez largement vous pouvez recevoir des
amis vous pouvez vous pouvez aller un
peu partout après le véritable adresse
vous avez dit voilà je te rappelle quand
même sur un revenu tel quel
à 30 ans nelson justin est victime d'un
grave accident de la route
la rééducation prendra du temps et
malgré son handicap il voit peu à peu
les portes des logements sociaux et
privés se fermer devant lui dans le
privé c'est assez rapidement c'est assez
facile à trouver on va dire c'est juste
les garanties qu qui pose problème soit
si la famille a pas de n'a pas les
moyens de poser garant pour faire si on
est tout seul n'a pas avoir accès
impossible
accompagné d'un travailleur social neil
delson se tourner vers l' agence soleil
après être passé en commission
son dossier est retenu il habite depuis
quelques mois dans cet appartement sur
saint denis
ce sont bien chez soi on est chez soi il
n'ya pas de contraintes ya pas de
personne pour dire quoi que ce soit on
est chez soi c'est le but qu'on cherche
se sentir bien chez soir déjà le but
principal
mais combien de temps il a fallu
attendre
j'ai 32 ans a fait ça fait bien 14 ans
que je suis sur le marché du travail que
je galère pour trouver un appartement
il a fallu que je passe pas à l'accident
une autre action de lagence soleil et
d'accompagner et de reloger les
personnes victimes de violences
conjugales au tampon cette mère de
famille nous parle de son passé et de
son avenir
une nouvelle viraux construite avec
l'aide de lagence et des travailleurs
sociaux
j'étais assistante maternelle j'ai dû
arrêter mon intégrité
donc j'avais plus de maison et donc plus
d'activités et trois enfants
et j'avais plus de toit j'avais une
maison à partir de là donc on rencontre
l'agent ce soleil qui vous trouvez
logement qu'est ce que ça fait c'est on
reprend de l'assurance on reprend on
reprend des forces
l'agent soleil m'a permis d'avoir un
toit et de par la suite de pouvoir
scolariser mes enfants me reposer et
réfléchir ce que j'allais faire après
après cela j'ai pu reprendre mon
activité avec près de 340 logements
locatifs sur l'ensemble de l'île
l'agent soleil répond à des urgences
sociales auprès de la population
réunionnaise
elle a également su convaincre les
propriétaires de biens privés d'adhérer
à leur projet alors les propriétaires
avec qui nous travaillons ou viennent
vers nous pour plusieurs raisons
certains par militantisme j'ai envie de
dire qu'ils savent qu'ils ont eu des
difficultés et souhaite vraiment que des
personnes puissent bénéficier de leur
logement
d'autres aussi par certains intérêts
dans la mesure où comme nous avons
beaucoup de demandes nous n'avons que
très peu de vacances au cati voire pas
du tout aux logements va tout de suite
occupé
nous avons bien entendu des garanties
l'état garantit en fait le paiement du
loyer
c'est actuellement la caution visage qui
est gratuite pour tous les propriétaires
nous avons un suivi de deux logements
grâce un conducteur de travaux qui va
accompagner et suivre le logement est
bien entendu les familles bénéficient
aussi d'un travail d'accompagnement
social
à 72 ans paul morel est propriétaire de
deux logements mis en location par
l'agent soleil aujourd'hui il rend
visite à une de ses locataires au petit
tampon men à quelqu'un oui bonjour
madame c'est michael moral
oui bah ça va bien et vous
une relation avec le locataire c'est
comment ça se passe by peut-on pages on
dit bonjour et on est con retard avec
toujours et par sa passe bien ça va être
bien des deux côtés ça parle bien avec
l'agent ça passe bien avec nous et voilà
c'est finalement c'est un peu des a
priori qu'on a en dix ans peut-être
qu'en mettant déjà en difficulté dans un
appartement dans une maison on peut
avoir des problèmes alors que c'est pas
le cas banon
si on met nous de notre côté oui c'est
un gros problème
un conte problème parce qu'après il faut
que oui a derrière les gens qu elle n a
pas les moyens de payer aujourd'hui
nous on a pas chez trakala l'agencé alba
elle va toulouse
le message que je voudrais faire passer
c'est que ceux qui ont des appartements
de libre aujourd'hui ne devrait
absolument pas hésité il devrait
s'adresser à ce genre de
dash ans qui n'hésite pas parce que
vraiment nous n'avons aucun problème et
ce sont des gens qui payent rubis sur
ongle si on peut le dire
et derrière il y a aussi les
responsables de l' agence qui veille à
ce que l'ambiance se passe bien à
pouvoir régler les problèmes s'il y en a
et vraiment nous n'avons aucune aucune
difficulté à ce jour pour à la fois être
payé de loyer et pour la tranquillité
des lieux
il existe aujourd'hui 45 agence
immobilière à vocation sociale au niveau
national l'agent soleil est la seule
présente à la réunion
elle compte huit salariés dont trois
travailleurs sociaux répartis sur deux
sites saint denis et saint pierre une
agence qui fête ses dix ans dix années
au service des personnes en grande
difficulté et des propriétaires privés
challenge qui est celui de l'agent
scouts se dire bien d'une part faisant
sorte que nos partenaires actuels soient
bien présents sur les années à venir et
d'une passion peut démultiplier les
partenariats avec les en sorte qu'ils
ont plus de partenaires pour asseoir
l'efficacité de la chance on va être
gagnant voilà donc un outil qui est
performant un outil qui mérite encore de
grandir un outil qui mérite encore
d'être accompagné l'intérêt de l'agencé
que c'est d'être ensemble les
collectivités locales l'état d'autres
partenaires les propriétaires et
locataires pour que tout ce petit monde
au grand coeur arrive de faire de bonnes
choses pour line